[موسيقى]
مع بزوغ فجر كل يوم جديد منذ خمسه اعوام
هنا بين جبال واوديه محافظه الليث غربي
السعوديه يعمل المزارع صالح الجبيري على
انجاح مشروعه الزراعي النوعي
اذ كون علاقه وطيده مع اسماك البلطي وفقات
تقنيات ووسائل زراعه حديثه تحت مسمى
البيوفوليك لينجح بذلك في انتاج
350 طنا سنويا بعدما كانت الفكره اشبه
بالمستحيله من سمكه تزاوج انثى مع ذكر
وتكون يدك على قلبك ينجح ما ينجح ومستهلك
يقبل بالمنتج ما يقبل هذه اشياء كلها ترى
كانت موجوده وكانت هواجس داخلي انه والله
ما مشروعه كاذب ينتهي بالفشل ولكن الحمد
لله مع الاصرار مع العزيمه مع مع استشارات
بعض الاصحاب يعني كانت محفزه وكانت
داعمليه اني انا استمر مهما كانت
[موسيقى]
مراحل متعدده تمر فيها زراعه اسماك البلطي
وتستمر لاشهر وفق انظمه غذائيه وظروف
بيئيه نحن نبدا من بدايه في التزاوج حتى
الفرز وهو انتاج اليرقات والبيض وثمه
التفريخ والتربيه بعد كذا ومن بعد كده
الاحواض التسمين اللي هي احواض التسويق
يعني من بعدها توصل المقاسات الى 100 جرام
نفس المشروع انا مصممه على انه الطاقه
الانتاجيه حقه من 5000 الى 7000 طن يوما
بعد يوم وهذا المزارع يشاهد حلمه يكبر
ويتطور امام عينيه اذ تبلغ مساحه المزرعه
حاليا 160 الف متر مربع
ويطمح الى ان تصل الى 500 الف متر مربع من
محافظه الليث سلطان السلمي العربيه